una vez que las llamas retrocede en el
silencio abrumador es lo más
sorprendente gran parte de la pequeña
ciudad de phoenix quedó reducida a
cenizas carbonizadas y para marian
tellers que es como si hubieran arrojado
una bomba sobre su casa
y este era mi camino de entrada
mi porsche lavadora y secadora nueva
no tenía idea de que no volvería a ver
mi piano o mi garage
normal
gran parte de oregón permanece envuelta
en una neblina tóxica de humo pero son
las ruinas las que más durarán en la
ciudad de lions están en todas partes
pero jeff que esto es un afortunado el
fuego se detuvo a escasos metros de su
casa
neighbors auster down
porque este link
la casa de un vecino se quemó pero el
departamento de bomberos tuvo mojar
todas las estructuras somos
increíblemente afortunados
y no solo son las viviendas lo que se
han perdido a pocos kilómetros de él
aaiún es un niño de 12 años y su abuela
murieron quemados vivos en su coche
intentaban huir pero el fuego se movía
más rápido que ellos en total unas
500.000 personas en oregón se vieron
obligadas a abandonar sus hogares para
hacer frente a este éxodo funcionarios
locales establecieron campamentos aunque
no sólo los humanos necesitan
alojamiento tenemos un montón de llamas
cerdos y cabras
y tenemos más creo que alrededor de 180
apoyos allí más de 400 mil hectáreas de
tierra fueron arrasadas hasta ahora en
unos incendios que ya son considerados
los peores en la historia del estado de
oregon